ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show uh day 68 of the SAG after
strike and the wga American crisis uh
Hollywood Insider someone here that can
help us make sense of this
time help us make sense of it Giannis
pop is the host of what is the name now
jannis pop is hour jannis pop is hour
yeah um help us make sense of this time
because here's the reality my mother
Last Wish she's dead when she was dying
she said before she died she's pay the
writers that was her final that was the
last thing she said she goes she goes
just pay the right she goes just pay him
yeah she jump ship when they turned on
Trump right on Fox she didn't want to
live in a world where Tucker Carlson was
not on
television right here's what I will say
about my mother
she got at at a decent time she had a
great run of America it was a good run
she did like that generation ironically
for her the Obama years were great for
this yeah area for the country and then
uh yeah Trump inherited a very booming
economy you know yeah she she lived
through a time where she made a lot of
excuses for Trump and Cheney a lot what
Obama do for the economy that made it so
good he was no drama Obama all they can
get on him is that his wife has a you do
you believe his wife do you believe he's
as we all big dick Mike he's it no but
let's be honest with you if I told you
Obama was gay let's be very honest yes
would you be a shocked
man would I be shocked if if I said
Obama's a bisx you would be shocked he
smokes Newports and he plays basketball
I'd be shocked why would he why would it
shock you that he's get do you do you
look at that I'm shocked he's got a
white mop do you look at that
relationship and think that that is
genuine absolutely really yeah what is
that based on black love it's placed on
R&B it's it's just so crazy I don't have
a gar like you got everyone I talk to
that says and listen by the way I'm Pro
that right I'm Pro him being gay and I'm
Pro Big Mike I'm the
progressive I'm actually the progressive
everyone El the Republicans are trying
to on him because they hate gay people
I'm a gay person who likes gay people
and thinks it would be pretty [__]
cool if we had a gay president and a and
a transfers lady here's the only thing I
don't understand if Michelle Obama is
big dick Mike as it's if she is Big Mike
don't make it vulgar well no is this off
YouTube already is this off you it's
probably off already right no this is
what she's called in the in the hashtags
on Twitter or X NWO yeah um since Elon
went Hollywood Hogan yeah um if Michelle
is Michael and those dick bounce videos
are true you never watch the the dick
bounce videos oh I have and by the way
can we can we ask what's going on well
this is what I'm skeptical of why is she
freeballing as a transgender woman good
talk good point don't they at least wear
Tommy John's credit where credit is due
why why is she not wearing boxing briefs
why is she wearing
1997 boxers think some days you think
you can get away with it
right but she knows she's going on Ellen
and she's gonna have to dance why would
she pick that day to wear old school
boxers if the bounce videos are real
she's
packing she's she's got she's got a nice
cut of meat for sure she ain't Irish
yeah if the bounce videos are real she's
not an Irish Catholic she's packing yeah
I'm listen all I'm saying is this I
don't have a problem like Abraham
Lincoln is rumored that he had a very
close relationship with the his friend
yeah I was about to say not his wife
yeah so like what does that make him not
a good president I don't think so it
makes him it makes him by so maybe Obama
was by maybe he's not maybe he's a
straight guy he did say and I'm sure
you've said this as a heterosexual man
he did say in a letter
I make love to men in my imagination you
know that that is a letter that Barack
Obama wrote to an ex I make love to men
every night but in my imagination I've
never said as a heterosexual man have
you said that ever no I've never thought
it unless the guy has taken a lot of
hormones and looks exactly like a girl
cuz by the way which is not that doesn't
even count hey I'm fooled but here's
what I'm what I'm saying is that I'm not
basing this on nothing the quote is I
make love to men daily but in my mind I
don't know what that means that might
mean I make love to men daily but in the
imagination that might be something he's
just saying to seemed cool to get [__]
right is that how men get [__] who know
was did he want to be an actor before he
became a politician it's very possible I
don't know and I can swim it's a good so
if I turn up in the East River we know
what happened
Mike but I I'm just saying we have to
get more evolved about how we look at
people you suggesting that his hot Chef
drowned in the twoot pool because an
affair between Obama and him was about
to come out as you put your cool mod D
sunglasses
on I don't know I'm just saying if I was
[__] a hot chef and by the way it
would be lovely yeah if I had a
hardbodied chef who paddle boarded every
day in my pond and then one day that
Chef came to me and
said you got to be who you are I'm
telling everybody about our
love that person would be
done so whose fault is it if that be if
that story is true whose fault is it the
chef it's the chef's fault you keep your
mouth shut keep your mouth I mean you
you know it's like they say in s
Scientology this is for sucking not for
talking is that what they say that's
what they say is that really what they
that's what they say wait a
minute yeah Dave what's his name David
misovich David movit said to Tom Cruz
remember this is for sucking not for
talking we have your a we know what you
think about men we know what you like to
do this is for sucking not for talking
right okay yeah is it a bad deal what
Scientology did for those people by the
way it's not at all a bad de not not a
bad deal at all right it's a nice deal I
think Leo reman is a rat she is
Technically she's a rat and I've said it
before all of them get famous
they all participate in that thing the
seaorg they torture the other people
they have to work 20 hours a day
whatever it is and then they decide once
they're famous and Rich they're not into
it anymore because you know why because
Scientology goes we want your kids right
to be in it now and then they go no yeah
that that's when they get a that's when
they grow a conscious after it's they've
done they've gotten everything out of it
that they can that's when they decide to
grow cont it's like asking a a murderer
to give an apology at court after he's
convicted I mean and he goes I'm sorry
it's like you should have been sorry
before you did it it to me I'm like they
went you wanted to do they went to Tom
Cruz and goes listen we know what you
like and the reality is we can protect
you we can protect you for decades you
can be the biggest star in the world we
just will create an alternative reality
of who you are and sell it to this
country of people
and Tom Cruz said great let's do it and
maybe John Travolta did I don't know I
don't know it's not my business and they
were repackaging an old uh
blackmail apparatus the old confession
right you do the audit so the Catholic
priest goes come come to confess and
then they go okay we know all your dirty
secrets now so you're going to have to
turn the other way well I go on this
date with this seven-year-old right
don't say
anything and then the audit s you do the
audit you tell all your dirty secrets
and Scientology goes now we got a vault
of all the guys yeah that you
slob and so now remember this is for
sucking not talking I told the priest
when I was 12 years old when I was 13 I
said I'm having these thoughts and
feelings I don't understand and he was
like why don't you keep him yourself you
fat
[__] that is a straight that was a
straight yeah that was a straight priest
that's a rare you quite a rare one
straight PRI yeah that's like an albino
tiger there's rare yeah well here's what
I will say um about this writer strike
which we are America is in crisis we're
not getting out it's like uh it's going
to be a long time it's like the
Afghanistan war David zazo Big Daddy zaz
yeah Ted Sandos Teddy Greek uh Donna
Langley I believe NBC Universal these
are all my best friends she is so
strange yeah for me but they I think I
actually heard through the Greek graev
that Ted Sandos loved your interview
with um what's his name again I think
his name is who um he's from Austin he's
he's a little famous Rogan no he liked
that one but he liked more the one with
Alex Jones Alex Jones yeah probably yeah
Ted Sandos was going let's put that on
Netflix I think but by the way he
definitely does here's a guy like that
private he's into it yeah yeah yeah what
because here's the what people don't
realize about life it's really boring
yes it's actually incredibly boring
especially if you're rich it's really
boring that's where drugs oros is so
bored he's so bored what's he going to
do buy another house stare at a few more
Dolphins marry another black woman so
when someone goes hey maybe Michelle's
got a hog or something he's tuning in
probably it's not more entertaining than
that it does not get more entertaining
than it's fun it's just fun yeah they
had a meeting with the writer Guild
everybody was hopeful about this I spoke
to people that you know know that
represent me they go yeah this is coming
to an end this was about a week ago the
amtp whatever it's called that's what
it's called they sit down with the wga
negotiating team now the wga negotiating
team is hardore like Old Brooklyn
marxists I respect them it's like Adam
Conover guys like that they don't give a
[__] they don't want to hear nothing
right they want they want it's like
Grapes of Wrath time with them respect
to them right they're doing their thing
everybody's playing their role so you
got them and then you got big daddy zaz
and the crew and Big Daddy zaz David zaz
is very offended at how mean everybody
has been to him because he decided to
pay himself a quarter billion dollars
because he thought he was worth it now
by the way if you don't realize your own
world worth who will no one will I mean
if someone is deciding their own salary
what are they going to do short sell
themselves crazy it's genuinely crazy to
expect David zaz love Big Daddy's zaz
which that's a brilliant merger uh
Warner Brothers and Discovery because
people they go why doesn't Warner
Brothers have more
investigation discovery and so he goes
for thinking of that brilliant idea he
paid himself a quarter Billy he's very
offended at how nasty people have been
to him he's very offended at how
directly they're going after him he goes
to College to speak they're booing him
they're chanting pay the writers all of
these billionaires are upset at how
personally this has been uh this has
gotten personal it's gotten ugly so thep
meets with the WJ and goes you have to
take our offer you have to take this
offer and it just Falls flat the WJ is
like get the [__] out of here yeah the
wga now is refusing to meet there's no
new there's no new meetings on the books
how do we solve it Giannis papus how do
we do it how do we change it I I don't
know this is kind of like the Russia
Ukraine it kind of feels like our
military operation in Afghanistan it's
going to go on for a good decade or two
yeah whoa yeah I just don't think it's
going to end that's crazy yeah I just
think that it's I don't see a solution
you think this will never end no I the
only place I can see Harmony between the
Marxist Union working class and uh the
elite of Hollywood is in J Robert's home
where she married a camera guy this is
an uncomfortable time for their
relationship that's very true she did
marry a camera guy married a camera guy
women are idiots yeah here's the thing
he's he's a union camera guy no and I'm
sure he's got a dick and you know he's
he's pounded around that's a love we can
believe in they're still together I
believe in that love and here here's
what I would say and you also believe in
Obama and his Chef's love I what I'm
saying is you're believer of that I know
that you're putting it out there that
that's an unreasonable thing to believe
not at all I'm saying is it any more
unreasonable than any of the other
things we're asked to believe about
people no I did not say was we were
asked to believe that Bill and Hillary
Clinton were in like love remember that
we were asked to believe that like Bill
Clinton and Hillary were in love with
each other that is love in Washington
that is love in Washington I don't know
about that every town has a different
type of Love okay that's maybe that's a
good point that's a good long island has
the love where we're going to it's just
eating we're in the culdesac we're going
to eat vast majority of it is eating in
racism yes yes racism Long Island you
want to find someone you can be racist
with while you eat yeah that's what it
is what's your definition of love in
Georgetown is it is it romance is it
let's go look at the cherry blossoms
it's Claire and Frank Underwood right
who do we have to kill right yeah so to
so so to me I don't know what's going on
with the Obamas but I just think all
possibilities are open all the time
Taylor Swift's on tour don't be such a
downer I'm not I'm I'm actually I think
it's fun and nice if uh he had a love
with the chef I think it'd be great I
think it'd be great we'll never know
because guess what and by the way those
are sometimes it is nice when you have a
love and then that love is gone yeah and
sometimes look when you're the most
powerful men in the world and maybe you
are straight and you're married maybe
you just want to have an affair with a
hot guy just because like you know I'm
bored bored and you know what you expect
that that Chef who's getting paid a nice
salary will know to keep his mouth CL
closed or else's going to drown in two
feet of water all these writers all
these writers that are saying to
themselves I want residuals I want more
money I want start a [__] podcast and
shut up you baby there you go there it
is there's the answer does anyone have a
putting furniture together yet podcast
start it there might be the answer find
and [__] go there's only there's only
10,000 of these you could be the 10 thou
10,000 and one we need 10,000 more is
there a podcast breaking down Tim Dylan
episode but isn't probably is but isn't
this class Warfare yes it's class
Warfare and it's ugly yes it is it's
ugly it's between the poor and the rich
well it's between the rich and the rich
no it's between the poor and the rich
they're not podcasters they're act
writers have money they're not three of
them no some of them have money few of
them a few of them have money and they a
lot of them have never made anyone laugh
so isn't that money that's like free
money if you're making money in comedy
and you've never made not a one person
laugh yeah isn't that free money it's
free money it's Casino money during the
last four years the casino opened and
everybody was able to walk in and you
got chips based on how uh diverse or
interesting or whatever you were and
they wanted to tell alized stories and
all that so it's you're playing with
house money yeah I mean you're talking
to the wrong person if you're looking
for sympathy from the writers and the
talent Executives they they said no to
me for everything so I've had to do
everything myself so I just say I just
say learn the code yeah I just say learn
the code it's a cold it's a cold harsh
reality yeah that hopefully they're
hearing now I networks don't want to do
pilots that don't make it to air anymore
yeah because Tim Dylan show is getting a
million viewers and we have no I I
believe I'm for
both I'm for both I'm for the writers
and the
billionaires because I have
integrity I want everyone to win right I
want everyone to win I want a
billionaire to wake up and be a you're
rooting a little bit for one side well
here's what I've said I've said I'm in
the middle but I will poison Adam
Conover if David zazo gives me a vial of
something to throw at him right I will
do that right that but just because I
like challenges I love spy novels but I
no I I I in this
War I think the only ground that I can
take is the middle ground right you know
where is which is where you live look I
I I like the CEOs better I aspired to be
like them I think they're good
people I think the writers have certain
points points you just got to like the
CEOs now thep has
suggested um that the writers start
drowning their
children now I say to that I understand
it and I understand why they're doing it
I don't agree with it I but they're
saying now a writer if you're a writer
and you cannot afford your child you
should drown it in the pool you can't
afford it's green that's very green as
well it's environmentally environment
sound look just pay these poppers before
they before they dive into your foyer
they attack your Lawns yeah just pay
these pop or something I was for the
writers I I was really I wanted to get
out there with Mark Ruffalo I wanted to
protest I wanted to hold my sign Mark
Ruffalo I wanted to get out there but it
when but when that side got nasty right
to the CEOs and started getting personal
very mean and started talking about
their salary don't like it that's
personal but that's out of bounds here's
the reality here's the
reality actors make a a lot of
money and then no one talks about that
nobody's talking about actors getting 20
million a movie Mark ruffo's not giving
it back nobody's talking about that
everybody is only talking about CEO
compensation right Mark Ruffalo and if
Netflix if I'm the only person who will
do all of the shows on Netflix yeah if
no one else will work if I have to scab
and be in every show if I'm that [__]
from Wednesday that doesn't blink if I'm
on Outer Banks if I'm everything if I'm
every [__] True Crime documentary if
I have to do every show in this country
HBO I you know they bring back a girls
reboot and I'm Lena Dunham which would
be I mean seamless but if if I have to
do that if I have to scab and do every
show I might have to do it yeah just put
Jimmy F just to make America happy yeah
and just put the Tonight Show on I don't
think they have writers The Tonight
Show do they have a host the Tonight
show hasn't been on that's a great point
I don't by the way no one is affected by
any of you know what's so funny go and
ask anybody like hey just ask a guy
working a construction guy be like how
are you doing without Cole bear they're
gonna go what they don't even know it's
happening they have no idea this is
happening that's part of the reason why
I think the uh the elite the
CEOs and the uh networks are going like
you guys got to meet us halfway because
these shows aren't making the money that
they used to make they don't make any
money nobody really cares the illusion's
kind of over people just want to watch
they're giv white guys specials again on
Netflix I mean they don't know what to
do there there is there's like three
that I can think of right now I know and
Taylor Swift I think a little bit of
that is sort of a backlash too where
people are just going like I'm T I'm
tired of names I can't pronounce I don't
even like Taylor Swift it's just nice to
see a blonde girl up there guy you know
what it is welcome back it should be
called the welcome home tour not the
erors tour it should be called this er's
white yeah J this is the white ARA it's
their fault it's their fault they got
two nuts with thees laugar ruges so
we're about fouri gabab Bingo yeah I
mean I don't know what city she's on
like but I think in the last leg of the
tour you might see a little of these at
her concert I've all and and by the way
now I'll go and it'll be 12-year-old
kids 12y old kids good it's just because
if you go too far one way the the the
backlash is is Taylor Swift every action
there's equal but opposite white
supremacy we can't do the crazy names
anymore I agree with you people just got
tired of Zimbabwe and ututu and canina
it can't happen Taylor how about Taylor
they just they watch one too many
specials of a guy sitting down doing
standup and they said I've had enough
people want to they want to remember
what white people in small towns having
high school type problems right yeah
boys and girls at the soda fountain
right this is what they want it's time
to go back to to that everything can't
be about your trans
abortion every show can't be about a
pregnant man we're back to 1950s
Pennsylvania Reading it's the glory time
factories dad and mom are working at the
factory dad's got a lunch pail and the
factory is Apple peie there are no
factories but it's it's a theme
restaurant that's right that everyone
can get behind yeah it's back to that
yeah what do you think about pran whose
dad ieni pran who is has I believe been
blown up accident yeah it was an
accident now everybody that can you just
imagine the pilots when they got in
there they went they go God you got
booked on this gig too well I was
talking about think they thought they
were G to land for one flight attendant
flight attendant going like hey man this
is not cool when they see him walk in as
the as the guest on the plane they go oh
yeah we're not we're not Landing no it
it was so and they they took out a wing
which you always know is bad they took
got a wing yeah and that's it's over
immediately and then the plane just
becomes a missile goes and and crashes
look if you cross Putin you fall from
the sky here's the deal people fall out
of Windows all the time around him how
do you feel now I know that you've you
you know you were a staunch supporter of
the
UK what's the
question you're a staunch supporter of
the Ukraine absolutely and and I
appreciate that I tattooed the Ukrainian
flag on both my daughters and and and so
to me what how are you feeling now are
you feeling like there's ever should we
ever negotiate with Russia is there ever
any reason to try to end the war no we
should only negotiate underground from
nuclear bunkers yes we have to go all
the way with this all the way all the
way let's let them fly let's let them
fly it makes sense yeah it's a win it's
a win-win situation it's a win-win
situation so I I will only how many C
ask you a question yeah have you were
you and your wife going to go to the
Ukraine before this happened absolutely
yeah yeah I mean I what is your favorite
had a tough time returning the tickets
on Expedia yes what is your favorite
food they serve there uh uh some type of
dumpling with with uh with sour cream
you know what the B of sour cream yeah
do you know the funny thing about that
food is it's kind of nondescript it's
just TR it's like trash European it's
all those Poland Slovak Russian and
they're like
here's here's sausage and here's some
Kut and go fight the Nazis or become
them and then they all claim it they're
like this is Polish food but they go
into a LV and and they're like this is L
great uh place I believe I forget it was
[__] I don't know it's in Greenpoint
there maybe it's called lman skaya great
Polish restaurant in Greenpoint there's
a lot of great Polish restaurants in
Greenpoint great for Polish food right
right well for that's like saying this
this place has a great hot dog yeah no
it's basically ballpark food they serve
you I went to a fourstar German
restaurant in Germany and they put a
ballpark Frank on my plate with
applesauce and like mustard I was like
this is your this is your that's what
they do yeah they're they're they're not
civilized I'm I want to go on a trip uh
I haven't been on a real like vacation
vacation yeah in a long time too hard
you really do I'm telling you right now
how long the show an hour it's an hour
and you do two of these a week two of
these a week it's a lot can we can make
that in a clip and say Dear actors and
writers yeah that's and writers Dear
actors and writers you see how hard we
work this is cold work but this is hard
work by the way hard and and here's the
reality I I I do acting as well
sometimes yeah and it's a lot of sitting
around yeah it's a lot of sitting in the
trailer no yeah we um we kept funny
going
while I support yeah the actors yeah me
too and David zlo and the fact that you
can't support them both is crazy no you
could like yeah I mean you support
Ukraine and Russia I want I you want
peace I support my union but I I will
scab that's why you're for Big Daddy's
ass yeah that's why you're voting for VC
Ramis Swami he wants peace I want
another podcast you're a non-war
podcaster should I run I'm literally
thinking about running for the governor
of California you should try I I may try
you should try and here's why yeah I
don't want the job right and I think
those that's an asset it is definitely
an asset because here's the deal yeah I
think I could cuz California is out go
to the flash mobs please there's so many
robberies in California right now gangs
of people run into these stores and just
flash mob well you call it robbery and I
would stop it you call it robbery I call
it how Society has failed these people
yeah I guess let's put on our headphones
to listen to
the flash
mob well news right now out
of mask thieves have smashed display
cases and sto a merchandise from
Nordstrom that's in the Westfield to
panga Mall let's go right to Jennifer
live in Koga park now she's got the
latest from there can't believe the
sanctity of our retail imagine the
mall your producer as a womaning so
definitely frightening for Shoppers and
employees who were in the store at the
time as several thieves entered and some
of this it was caught on camera some of
it was
caught they're searching yeah who's to
say they're not playing Finding Nemo
here's my issue with this they call this
a victimless crime but the reality is
it's violent there are people that could
get hurt right no this is a victimless
crime do you think that's victimless
yeah I would you really believe that's
victimas yeah you if you believe if I
was a cop I would say I'm sorry guys how
has Society failed you yeah yeah yeah
it's CRA but but literally the da and
people like that are saying and I'm open
to the debate you know that guard was in
on it yeah the guard's absolutely in on
it and not just cuz he's black
yeah just because he didn't move right
just cuz he was waving saying hey what's
up I'll see you at home yeah I'll see
you yeah you got my bag right the what I
told you to grab it's here's the thing
about when me and him get together it
sounds racist but it's not but it's not
no it's not that's the thing but it's
actually not I actually think he was
maybe a Dominican gu hearing things but
it's not what it sounds like no no no no
he just wasn't moving yeah he's just but
he was just kind of like he was just
kind of like I get it cuz he's not
getting paid a lot I'm not going to die
to guard a a tote bag yeah they're
saying it's a victimless crime now take
your headphones off because now we can't
both that looks odd yeah people are
running into these stores it's Smash and
grab people are going hey it's a
victimless crime lighten up who cares
don't worry about it it's a brilliant
crime you roll in with 40 people there's
too many people to arrest it's
pandemonium and people walk out with a
couple of fendy bags yeah big deal well
it is a big deal who's getting hurt a
lot of people a lot of people like who
here's who's getting hurt with this
prove to me one person who got hurt by
this I got to prove it right now yeah
the people that are going to lose their
jobs when these stores close because
that's what happened in San Francisco oh
so everybody that works in the store and
then the store's basically going to go
we are not going to St here just like
they did in San Francisco what color are
the people working there everybody who I
mean is this even allowed on Apple
podcast I'm just I don't even know I'm
just saying that's cuz look at all the
stores that are leaving these are all
the places that are leaving San
Francisco all the places that are
leaving okay right Depot Marshall Crate
and Barrel H&M Unico anthropology abran
fit Nordstroms Nordstrom s a gap DSW now
you're a conspiratorially oriented guy
so let me ask you a question is This
Disaster capitalism will Naomi Klein
write a book about this is this
Blackstone intentionally throwing these
flash mobs in there so the prices dip
down they get a going at of business
sale they turn it into one big Costco no
I think it's paralysis capitalism I
think that people are paralyzed and
don't know what to do and think that
we've gotten uh ourselves into a
predicament where unfortunately the
levers of government and bureaucracy are
grinding at a pace where nothing can get
done and nothing unfortunately there's
no will nobody has any will anymore to
make something happen right so people
are just stuck trying to be a good
person going like hey man I don't know I
wasn't in that store I wasn't affected I
don't live in down San Francisco I live
in Marin County I got a mansion I'm not
going to worry about it until they're in
my window I don't think people are
worried about anything that's not
directly affecting them and I think the
politicians are just saying whatever
they have to say yeah um to seem like
they're good people and that they're you
know uh evolved and that they are
considering all the Angles and I think
it's paralysis I I mean listen these are
the wealthiest people in the world it's
weird they're letting this happen I
understand conspiracy theories people
going why are they doing this why are
they letting it happen right I think
it's paralysis I think it's people just
not wanting to say the uncomfortable
things you would need to say to fix this
like that was a crime like that's a
crime that's that's illegal like those
people need to go to jail like people
that are doing heroin on the street are
not just poor right like people that
live in tent cities in many cases are
choosing to live there and use drugs
because it's an open air drug Market
where they can procure the drugs that
they're addicted to what you're saying
those are unpopular things to say right
what you're essentially saying is Optics
have become more important than reality
and are more concerned with the Optics
than they are the reality and we've
created a world where people are not
affected that's the thing people are not
affected by how bad it's getting in the
next town not yet they're not yet not
yet not yet not yet but here's the thing
it it's always it's like anything else
right if you ignore something and it
festers it
becomes eventually a problem that has to
get dealt with raising in the sun it
explodes but when people go oh these
flash mobs what do you think drove all
those stores out of San Francisco this
[__] inequality and then by the way if
there's no stores people don't want to
live in San Francisco and then people I
don't want to live downtown my wife
can't go to the store my gay husband
who's a twink can't go to the store
whatever it is we know lesbians can
always go anywhere no matter what but
there are PE there are certain people
that are more delicate the more more
important in society the lesbians let's
be frank they're the Marines of
gentrification sure they are but what
else do they do I know they can they can
pickle things and you they can throw a
softball Prett they they can run a bar
yeah they can hit you with a bat they
can build a sh but I mean it's they are
they evolving culture let's be honest
yeah uh my point is the reality is this
is the beginning of a rot in a city that
comes to you know comes to to be a bad
Omen for a lot of things so those are
the people that get hurt all the
legislators are hijacked by um gotcha
politics everyone's doing slam dunks on
each other nobody's talking about policy
you watch these debates and local level
all the way up to the federal level it's
just all personal attacks now it's like
we're watching wilding out it's like a
this battle it's just going like and
you're going like all right we're
hearing about Hunter Biden's emails or
Hillary's emails or Trump's indictment
you're going does anyone want to talk
about policy yeah does anyone want to
talk about how we can stop the mob from
you know now who has policy ideas has
there been a flash mob for food does
anyone run into like California Pizza
Kitchen with guns and go where's the
Because by the way everyone talking
about how they're starving well that's
well AOC talks about these people are
starving and they are starving fendy
bags worth a lot and so they all sell
these bags right they sell these bags
now get money for food groceries I will
say this they all did look thin if you
want to catch all those guys all you got
to do is put cameras on at Whole Foods
get the George gascan thing up where he
goes uh you know he's talking about and
this is the da of I believe Los Angeles
right yeah and this is the da of La when
he's asked about these things because by
the way I don't really shop that much so
I don't you know you know
understand uh not caring about this
right but it is something where I look
at it and I go oh this is the beginning
of something that could probably you
know be weird so it's just hitting you
now that things are bad well no no no I
just these are it's a new the flash mob
is kind of interesting oh it's been
around for a long time it's been around
for a long time it's a little fun it is
fun I get the appeal of it like by the
way I'm a human being I understand it's
fun going let's run in let's grab some
[__] and let's leave
here's George gascan here yeah this guy
looks like a deer in headlights I mean
this guy is just he looks he's the da
yeah right now in the face of uh the
flash mobs yeah he's got soft eyes he
looks he doesn't really know what to do
yeah and he's being asked a question and
here put on the
um put on head put on the headphones
yeah let's hear what he says and you
could hear them
oh God he looks like the old coach
available under the law when there is an
arrest made to make sure that this
individuals are hell accountable LA
mayor Karen bass also spoke about
accountability saying in part quote
those who committed these acts and acts
like it in neighboring areas must be
held accountable but not everyone feels
like local leaders are delivering on
that promise businessman Rick Caruso
said quote I have heard directly from
small business owners who who feel
defeated by the lack of accountability
for criminals what do you say to the
person who points a finger at you saying
that there are people in this community
who believe they can get away with
serious crime in LA county and not be
held accountable well I would ask you
the question why would you tell him when
you just heard me speaking right now
because I think you have a
responsibility also for addressing it we
will use every tool available under the
law journalist has a responsibility get
out there and make a citizen arrest why
is this guy not in Miami sitting on a
cabana yeah I mean he's perfect he like
what are you talking about we got a
problem here you have to Vis it yourself
I mean we're all here born in America
you know what's coming here you come
here they get the hat back everybody had
to be responsible for what they doing we
see the people we're going to make them
responsible we're in Los Angeles yeah
yeah I don't know what uh what that is
is what his thing is why he's even why
you see these people don't care about
they're appointed these guys aren't is
he are da is elected he's elected yeah
who votes for this stuff they don't know
this is the I I I've lived there five
years who's voting and how long are
these terms and yeah comp troller is
also elected I can't tell you what he
does yeah right they recalled the guy in
San Fran this guy Chessa buen they
recalled him they were like you are
really [__] up oh that guy he was
basically like telling people that were
stabbed to get over it yeah he was going
stop locking your store at night
right 35% of all fatal accidents occur
between 600 p.m. and midnight people age
25 to 34 of the highest amount of
drivers involved in car crashes people
age 15 to 24 who's driving in 15 but
people aged 15 to 24 have the highest
rate of emergency room visits due uh to
car accidents of all age groups by the
way and and and Morgan and Morgan is
America's largest injury Law Firm they
have a 100 offices Nation wide 800
lawyers $15 billion recovered over
300,000 clients Morgan and Morgan has a
proven track record of fighting to get
you full and fair compensation Morgan
and Morgan has been fighting for the
people for over 35 years suban injury
claim with Morgan and Morgan is so easy
life is hard submitting an injury claim
with Morgan and Morgan is easy you got
to do it folks got to do it can't not do
it you can't afford not to if you're
ever injured you can check out Morgan
and Morgan their fee is free until they
win for more information go to for
thee. timtim or dial pound law pound 529
from your cell phone that's fthe
people.com Tim or pound law pound 529
from yourself this is a paid
advertisement that's capitalist hooa
yeah I mean so what's going on up there
I just read this tweet Texas Attorney
General Ken Paxton and now indicted
Austin investor Nate Paul set up a fake
Uber account Paxton used to see his
lover revealing the extent of the men's
ties and benefits Paxton received by
helping Paul as the FBI targeted him a
new impeachment trial filing says I mean
anyone who gets into politics is really
just trying to do it in most cases to to
have enough power to kind of like cover
up whatever crimes they're committing
yeah that seems to be it and whatever
Gay Thoughts they may have maybe I mean
nobody because by the way is there a
shittier life than being a politician
like if you're an honest person that has
yeah but look at all the other better if
you're a really bright smart guy there's
Finance there's Tech there's
entertainment you could do whatever you
want yeah politics does seem to attract
a certain type of person that wants to
have the power maybe to cover up [__]
they do right right it's weird like I I
was talking to Louis about it it's like
there's just a specific right type of
guy that gets into politics that rises
through the ranks that stays in it no
different from any other field though no
it is though people who don't sweat when
a body goes down is people who get to
the top that's true people with low
empathy yeah yeah will always rise to
the top yeah so you need you need not
have empathy is is the is is really you
really it's it it it's helpful in our
country to be a sociopath helpful I mean
it's an understatement yeah I mean who
wants to be encumbered by guilt or
morals or but our job I don't think so
because I think you got to relate to
people right right and Amy Schumer
didn't turn down the Barbie movie
because it wasn't feminist enough right
like she said
right well I support I support her I
don't support that movie because she was
not Barbie she should have been Barbie
she should have been Barbie someone from
our community so we got some [__]
London broad taking our jobs did you see
Barbie of course not oh a lot of people
saw it I haven't seen it yeah yeah no I
put on my pink dress and checked it out
are you sure I don't know I don't know I
I haven't seen it I don't really have an
opinion on it I went to Oppenheimer yeah
I saw that a little long little long and
Brilliant at the end but by the way it's
a bit long everyone's walking no one
needs three hours of anything now yeah
and why does every scene start with
people walking yeah well it just gives
you that feeling that a rap video meets
a 60 Minutes interview yeah yeah is
Michael ba I wish I could play the
trailer for The thing that I'm not
allowed to talk about cuz I'm in Sag
because it's a good trailer but I won't
talk about it it doesn't matter which
which thing is that a thing I didn't do
that I'm not promoting that I'm not
allowed to discuss because I'm in the
Screen Actor are you in the Screen
Actors Guild I don't think I'm in
Hollywood I don't
think
um you could say yeah know you I think
you had to be though because you did
Comedy Central you I'm sure I'm in it
but listen let's why don't you get out
there with a [__] sign and put your
money with your mothers because I'm
playing the long game I'm preparing for
the Christian ayatolla who's going to
come back and throw gays in prisons 90%
I'm straight I like women 90% of actors
protesting this have never worked they'
have no money no this is true yeah and
they're out there 87% of people in Sag
make less than $26,000 a year right so
it's unfortunate and move to Austin it's
tough you can't afford that it's more
expensive than La well live under a
bridge what do you want me to tell you I
Austin is so expensive right now I was
reading about it it is a crunch yeah if
you were living in that City over the
last few years and you haven't found a
way to financially better yourself you
are [__] yeah Joe better get more
bodyguards because cost of living a
family of four estimated monthly cost is
now
4241 yeah without rent by the way listen
to that again
a family of four estimated monthly cost
Austin 4241 without rent right the
zombies are going to storm the comedy
Mothership at some point good luck no
they're gonna get they're gonna get up
there and start doing
sets and kill Tony yeah yeah yeah no
it's it's it's it's a very expensive
city now um you know because this is
what Happ when things get hot Miami is
the most it's like the most expensive
city in America I know it's become a
little unbearable and I love Miami so I
hate to say that yeah Miami's become so
expensive that people just can't they're
just diving into the ocean well that's
the thing about Californians they
swimming back to Cuba yeah The
Californians move places and they make
it more expensive but they they they
make them worse that's true yeah
Californians don't they're not they
don't have a the right type of edge to
them they don't have the fun type of
edge they're like they they got their
socks and shoes off they're putting
pecans in salads the problem with people
from that state is they're too laidback
yes and what happens is they don't care
about anything yeah and then what
happens is eventually someone does care
and and the whoever cares is a problem
yeah anyone I meet in Los Angeles either
doesn't care or they're like manic on
pills yeah there's no in between there's
no middle class there there's nobody
who's there's no middle class of Sanity
in Los Angeles there's nobody who's a
little crazy no right everybody is full
nuts or checked out they're checked out
right like you'll see this families in
Malibu they're all dressed in white they
look like a cult and they're just
sitting there and they're kind of eating
strawberry sorbet and they're all just
staring at each other and you go yeah
they don't care that everybody is a
flash M maybe the flash mobs will get
bigger I don't know which side to join
maybe I shouldn't be maybe I should just
start flash mobbing like there we'll get
to a point where we have to pick a side
we have to go is it the flash mob
because maybe they're stronger and more
powerful right so it it there is a point
where you know oh just always side with
the Christian ayo's that's where you got
to go prob go back to church and just
pretend there is going to be I do feel
we've talked about this a swing back to
Evangelical Christianity for order it's
the only thing that can that can put
Pandora back in the box it's the only
thing that can put the Jack back in the
box it's the only thing that can hold
this thing together get raped by the
people you know and trust that's right
yeah that's right someone you call
Father right right it's cu the people
forget that they they the the real human
trafficking I mean obviously there's
examples of it everywhere but like a lot
of it is organized religion most of it a
lot of it is organized religion and and
by the way even during the Franklin
Scandal those kids were coming out of
boy town like there's always been the
Catholic church was set up by Robin
nobleman to yeah rape children well
listen I'm going to my mother's wake
tomorrow we let's not talk about the
Catholic Church in a negative way what
do you mean let's not talk about it no
they've done a lot of good if you've
been to St Patrick's Cathedral it's
stunning yeah but everyone limestone is
stunning by the way they they had to
stand outside and guard it with hatchets
real estate means something it's
beautiful it's gorgeous if I wanted to
rape a bunch of children I would have
targeted the Irish too cuz you people
don't say nothing and know how to take a
look at how beautiful that is get up how
many [__] how much limestone is in
that church it's a lot do you know how
many little boys were fed to Bishops
like tokens to make that thing are you
Catholic or not I'm not Catholic Oh my
God what are you I'm Greek Orthodox
that's a freak Church no you know you
have a weird thing that looks like a
mosque by Ground Zero yes and it and it
looks like a mosque and we rebuilt it
what is that what is the Greek Orthodox
church it's Catholicism with lamb
basically except the priests can marry
can marry expected to marry I like that
and we don't rape millions of boys but
here's the deal you have no money your
country is bankrupt that's correct you
do not have a Vatican or a Vatican bank
right you have zero power yes yes oh we
do have we do make a killer frae you and
you have great and I like Ava and we we
love restaurant Ava great in Beverly
Hills and New York but the Beverly Hills
one's a little better and we have the
healthiest diet and we love to talk
about Antiquity the same but also we
can't exempt the Greeks from the charge
of pedophilia let's be honest no they
started like everything let's be honest
let's just they uh we can't say that
they had nothing to do with that they
started it that's like telling saying
that Irish people have nothing to do
with
alcoholism when in popular culture it's
all they've ever done is be drunks right
because a lot of them are drunks but it
wasn't like ordinary Greek citizens in
Athens or sparter were raping children
it was the elites right in city states
just like throughout every Empire the
Ottomans and The Sultans and uh the
Roose Empires I'm sure other people were
doing it but they're the ones that got
away with it right well people get rich
and powerful and they get weird they
want to drink the blood of children what
do you want from me yeah but the
Catholic Church they do it they're the
Michael Jordan of raping children I know
but don't you see any positives with the
Catholic church because let's be very
honest there are
positives and and and no and and you
what are they the positives yes of the
Catholic Church what are they it's the
one true Faith okay I forgot about that
it has the most stunning real estate in
the world it's feminist because they
love Mary it's the most stunning real
estate in the world some of the most
stunning art right in the world right
we're talking about Rome we're talking
about a civilization here yeah that has
lasted for a very long time the
Antiquity the magic the rituals the
spirits it's important okay you won me
over
I forgot about like how many do you
think they've got away with because they
did a recent uh expose in France and
since the 70s I think they came up with
300,000 children have it's probably 10
times that my point is this and that's
just France it's a particular area who
is leaving their kids alone with priests
who is letting your kid be an alter boy
bolivians you
should you should watch your kid in a
church like the way you'd watch them in
Time Square you should yes yeah no I was
never an ultra boy if they're doing that
in France what do you think they're
doing in Bolivia I know where there's
there's bad things happening yeah here's
the thing how many people have been
abused by the Catholic Church report
estimates to
216 216,000 children were abused by the
Catholic priest between 1915 2020 it's
probably so much more I mean come on
Catholic Church employees increased the
total number with 330 cuz they saw it
well listen it's weird listen being a
priest and saying I'm not going to marry
and I'm not going to have any sex my
whole life right it would attract people
that have problems right no I think it
was set up for that it was set up for
that and they recruit yeah because think
about it look it the confession it only
the confession is blackmail let me
finish then they take the women and they
remove them and put them in the coment
the women got to go someplace else who
tends to blow the whistle on Abus of
children women right right so it's it's
brilliantly set up but you know that
priest could marry up until a point
where they decided until the pedophiles
took over but they didn't want priests
leaving their property to their sons oh
so it was actually a money thing like
everything else it started about money
and the church was like we want all this
property we don't want priests to own it
I so we don't want priests marrying and
then having heirs I just like to look at
the data and go hm maybe it's set up for
that if we're talking those type of
numbers yes Giannis but you know what
every single religion has a lot of
problems and there's a lot of
molestation in every religion and not
every religion has a lot of money except
Islam has no problems I agree with that
yeah I agree that's right we're in
agreement I agree with that absolutely I
agree I agree too I agree yeah and
Judaism Judaism has none I I you know
what I agree with I agree with that
except for those two I agree with
Judaism being not a problem whatever
whatever yeah I everything Israel does
is cool Catholic and Protestants are the
problem Islam and Judaism not
Protestants are are listen and I don't
want to say anything wrong here right I
don't want to say anything wrong right I
will Protestants are dirty pig people
they're dirty pig people we agree again
sorry
yes
sorry they're kind of like loow like
their churches are like Shacks they're
disgusting they set up shop wherever
they are H if your church if you if I'm
walking into a building on Christmas and
it's not nice yeah what are we doing
yeah what are we doing it's like the bar
show scene of religion you know Telecare
still exists which is a Catholic Church
Channel Telecare it's like long like my
grandparents used to watch it and my
grandparents used to watch a bill donah
who who's like the head of the Catholic
league and all these people right um is
it still on it's got to be still on yeah
I think so it's on Verizon FiOS in Long
Island and it's Channel 271 and you can
watch telare
now I want you so let's can we play a
little of this here this is the Catholic
faith like this is the type of stuff
that they would have now obviously this
is from a while ago this is but this is
the type of stuff this is from 2012 I
love it but this is the type of stuff
that they would have on Long Island
television dude I remember all I all my
I had so many Irish friends I would go
to Catholic Church I'd eat the wafer I
remember my grandparents would watch
things like this let's take a look
everybody I'm on the brand new set of
our news program everyday F Live Hope
had a great summer my Sor Jim VOR here
to tell you that next week it all starts
on telare new season new episodes of
everyday Faith live all kinds of new and
exciting stuff we've been working all
summer long to give you brand new
programming that speaks to Faith that
speaks to spirituality and that informs
you about our Catholic faith in this
world so don't forget tune in to
Everyday Faith live it all starts next
Friday live at 10:30 a.m. here on telare
now they probably have podcast right
they have I mean there's no way they
haven't evolved and with the times I
mean all I know is that the don't you
have any respect for the size and the
sheer scope of the Catholic Church
they're the second biggest land owner in
Washington DC is that not something that
impresses you that is very impressive
thank you the first biggest land owner
in Wason wait a minute hold on is the
federal government this four weeks ago
is that Telecare uh this is Catholic
faith Network let's see what that is
let's see what this guy's doing Catholic
no the one that's up there from a couple
of weeks ago okay here we go yeah
reflection oh this one it's in Spanish
it's in Spanish you know it's funny oh
no forget it every one of these but
they're very faithful that's why the
Hispanics every one of these guys looks
apart too they all looked apart they all
kind of looked apart well Bill donu the
Catholic League was this guy who would
just come out and again you know I you
had to it was interesting during the
Iraq War and they had to come out and go
torture is Catholic like
Catholics I like the you know what I
mean like Catholic shows on Long Island
like Bill O'Reilly and all those guys
who tried to get his WX communicated
they had to there was a challenge cuz
they had to come out and basically go
you know enhanced interrogation is
actually like Catholic right and so
these housewives in Long Island New York
that were watching and hearing the news
reports of like you know people being
you know naked and stacked in pyramids
and having dogs bark at them and being
beaten and waterboarded these guys had
to come out and say this is God doesn't
have a huge problem with this no no no
God's actually okay with this yeah we're
ready to apologize to Galileo's family
and descendants right right so that was
what it was very interesting it's an arm
you know the kind of the Catholic church
is it's always been kind of an arm of
the political realities of whatever time
we're in right it's a you know it's a
public relations thing that big time Big
Time and but but but but maybe it's
true yeah maybe there's some truth to it
there might be some truth to it Boston
Globe wrote about it but who can trust
the media nowadays anyway but but here's
the deal the church is not the crimes
the church has committed the church is
the people the church is the people the
church is the people the church is not
the crime the church is God the church
is God you have something so telare
became the Catholic faith Network put
something on from this so they have a
cooking show with with preachers now
that's good but this is what we want
cathic content real food and it's you
know what it's about it's about cooking
real food for God
yeah okay real food I mean this guy he's
I mean this
guy he doesn't turn down extra now when
he goes you want seconds he goes welcome
to real food today we're going to be
going against the grain and preparing
two quick and healthy meals using two
greens barley and pH this guy's a boy
addiction and a food addiction hey let's
not call the guy a pedophile with
absolutely no evidence none at
all I'm sorry to maybe suspect
he's like the thing I like about these
grains is they're
young they're really young talking about
barley now it's a funny thing with
barley I don't know about your life when
I was a little guy uh my mother used to
make beef barley soup you know from
scratch but barley was always kind of
something that they fooled me with they
told me that was a pasta so I used to
think that barley was like a kind of
macaroni and then when I found out it
was a grain I didn't want to eat it
anymore so that's kind of the
interesting thing so now when you go to
like your specialty
already made and you can buy a little
pound of this and a pound of that and
take it home one of the things that's on
every single supermarket food uh kind of
display is barley a barley salad and
it's so inexpensive and so easy to make
we shouldn't be afraid of these greens
should be
afraid don't be afraid of these greens
don't be afraid sometimes you make him
in dark rooms you think he slipped up a
couple Tes like love I mean great simple
now what I'm making right now does not
have meat in it but
I I like I like do that later I'm just
going to show you so we're going to
start with first of all is some
asparagus I love asparagus um asparagus
is just a it's a terrific um and the boy
of food did I say that so it's a great
one to kind of utilize so I'm just cut
the edges off now sometimes people break
them so I'll show you one way you can do
this
spot usually we're already
off this episode already been banned
from everything YouTube's getting with
it I I'm just saying we have no proof of
anything I'm no no we're just we're just
we're joking joking we're joking and
actually we didn't accuse them of
anything right that's a good point I was
never touched by a priest yeah the AP
you saw my best efforts
right um you know but here's the thing
man I mean it's it's complicated right
cuz I'm going to my mother's wake and
it's we're doing a funeral mass and it's
Catholic so what do you want me to do
like in your church just look up the
background your church has problems too
we do there's a corruption but we don't
there's a lot of corruption we don't
tend to have uh child the child abuse
that the Catholic church is being no the
Catholic church has a serious problem
with that they're being accused of it at
least I'm Jewish right I support Israel
I'm Jewish I I be Jewish you can support
Israel I do you can't be je I think they
should have all the land they want
absolutely who cares they're never
trying to conquer the world no people
accuse them of it but they're not I'm
serious why are people not mad at the
Germans or the or Stalin or people who
actually are us they're Israel is just
saying give me one
kabutu little by the way people are mad
at the Germans and us they should be are
but Israel I think uh you know whatever
they that boy they want a tiny little of
a schmack aack they want a little
schmeckle that Palestinian toddler had a
look in his eye he was going to do
something he was a
problem I don't know Giannis pop is
where can people find you see you enjoy
your comedy stylings the jannis yeah the
jannis papis hour is my podcast I think
you really enjoy it check it out um see
me on the road New York City Sony Hall
uh San Francisco Portland Vancouver uh
every where go to jannis paisc
comedy.com come see it's not just the
abuse of Catholics no cuz my
grandparents that was my last special
they'd be so angry with you if they
heard this I'm sorry to bring all this
up but you know um but you know what it
is I've heard a few rumors you do this a
lot where you attack Catholics iath
because we're like some punching bag for
your broke ass people it's my fault what
happened you your broke ass pedophiles
in
greas you're broke broke ass pedophiles
we we do not have you always [__] on
Catholics cuz you see our church you got
a little mosque Church down by Ground
Zero we're in Fifth Avenue [__]
good
point come see me Tim Dillan comedy.com
where we will not be abusing the
Catholics at all we understand that
things happen uh parks cassino in Philly
Los Angeles Charlotte Lexington
Cincinnati Davenport Omaha Sacramento or
Australia Perth Adelaide Sydney
Melbourne Auckland Christ Church those
are in New Zealand Rochester New York
New York New York Carnegie Hall
Pittsburgh uh music called Detroit
Michigan Toronto Ontario and that's
pretty much the rest of the year um the
great Giannis PO is Giannis pois hour on
YouTube go subscribe to that show right
now uh go see Giannis on patreon go see
him live tickets are available on your
website what is your site giannisis
comedy.com jannis paisc comedy.com maybe
you want to bring your grandparents in H
tell them why everything they believe
their whole Life's a
lie how about that good night everybody
and good
luck